élections provinciales en nouvelle
calédonie première victoire celle de la
légalité 60 % de votants dans le calme
le rpcr anti-indépendantistes tient une
majorité relative entre les discours sur
la solidarité et la réalité il ya
l'exemple de l'hôpital de garches pour
les handicapés l'éducation nationale
décide de supprimer six postes
d'enseignants au désespoir des parents
qui voudraient que leurs enfants soient
le plus possible comme les autres tennis
roland garros la victoire des enfants
après mademoiselle sanchez 18 ans hier
l'américain michael chang 17 ans
remporte la finale face au suédois
hedberg en cinq sets et quatre heures de
match que vous avez pu suivre en direct
ça peut être cet après midi sur antenne
2 et dont nous vous présenterons les
meilleurs moments à la fin de cette
édition
madame monsieur bonsoir nous
commencerons ce soir par un sujet qui
dérange c'est aussi notre devoir de
journaliste en cette période de campagne
électorale riche en promesses comme
d'habitude mais entre le discours et la
réalité il ya l'exemple de l'hôpital de
garches dans la banlieue parisienne qui
accueille les accidentés de la route et
tous les autres handicapés dans cet
établissement
l'éducation nationale a décidé l'année
prochaine de supprimer six postes
d'enseignants et comme toujours en
pareil cas on se rejette la
responsabilité face à des parents
désespérés en quête de marque maison
neuve et france brice garches vitrine de
la recherche française en matière de
handicap des adultes y sont soignés mais
aussi des enfants les enfants dont les
traitements longs en nécessaire une
hospitalisation longue
au cours de celle ci il doit être
scolarisé parce qu'en france l'école est
obligatoire jusqu'à 16 ans et que pour
eux c'est bien souvent la seule
possibilité d'ouverture sur le monde
pourtant à l'intérieur du rectorat de
paris qu'on ne semble pas persuadé de
l'utilité de donner à ses enfants un
enseignement normal allant jusqu'à
profiter d'un vide juridique
elle existe dans les faits mais pas sur
le papier les personnes d'empressement
solide dans l'enceinte d'un hôpital de
l'assistance publique les bâtiments de
l'école ils appartiennent à la mairie de
paris
et c'est le rectorat
pensent les crédits trois
administrations différentes et aucun
protocole d'accord pour officialiser
cette situation cela fait douze ans que
cela dure n'a fonctionné à l'autre le
dossier change de mains parce qu'on
gestionnaires avisés ils savent ce que
risque de coûter la signature d'un tel
protocole jamais les responsables scène
ministre hâtif n'ont vu l'un de ses
enfants
c'est un enfant qui n'a aucun tonicité
musculaire et qu'ils se parlent in some
qui a presque paralysée elle va à
l'école elle va l'être à la gare
auxquels elles ont voté à l'école parce
que fait elle a besoin
comme tous les autres enfants
d'apprendre et de de socialiser un petit
peu c'est une enfant qui a vécu pendant
les quatre premières années de sa vie
entre sa maman et son papa vent et un
rêve me rendre mais l'action est allée à
l'école comme exemple qui a le droit
d'être enseignée est-ce qu'il faut être
un bon footballeur pour être enseignée
est-ce qu'il faut être un enfant qui
court pour elle y enseigne à partir du
moment où on s'écarte du schéma habituel
on s'aperçoit que il n'y a pas de
structure il n'y a pas de réflexion qui
permettent d'envisager cette affaire-là
ji ce qu'il veut mais le rectorat de
paris dont défendre les écoles décident
six postes d'enseignants sont supprimés
à la rentrée prochaine
ni les directeurs d'école ni les
instituteurs n'ont pu commenter cette
décision
leur hiérarchie leur a interdit de
répondre à nos questions on ne justifie
pas l'inavouable pourtant l'enseignement
et leurs droits comme à tous les autres
enfants
en nouvelle calédonie le principal
résultat des élections dans les trois
régions n'est pas a comptabilisé en
chiffre ce qu'il faut d'abord retenir
c'est que le vote a eu lieu dans le
calme et que les votants étaient
nombreux 60%
les habitants du territoire de tous
bords ont donc avant tout dit oui à la
légalité quant aux résultats en sièges
une majorité relative pour les anti
indépendantistes du rpcr rachid arhab la
mairie de la petite ville de poya est le
symbole de la nouvelle carte politique
néo calédonienne nord sud
cette commune fait la frontière entre la
province qui sera dirigée par le rpcr et
celle qui sera géré par le fn ps le fn
heynckes qui prend mais également les
îles de nouvelle calédonie les deux
principales composantes du territoire
confirme donc leurs forces respectives
dans le nouveau congrès les anti
indépendantistes auront 27 sièges
majorité relative 19 sièges pour les
indépendantistes les petites listes sont
laminés les extrémistes presque oublié
il y a eu aucun incident le calme absolu
dans lequel la campagne électorale et le
scrutin se sont déroulés et le taux
élevé de participation montre que le fus
lq qui appelaient au boycott et menacé
de créer des incidents est largement
dépourvue de toute représentativité ce
mouvement d'ado aucune légitimité à se
prétendre notamment sur la scène
internationale représentatif de la
communauté bel abbésienne de nouvelle
calédonie louis le pensec t le
gouvernement peuvent donc être satisfait
la nouvelle calédonie semble à nouveau
stabilisé malgré la disparition de jean
marie tjibaou
mais les extrémistes accepteront-ils le
verdict des urnes
ce que l'on retient donc ce soir rachid
arhab c'est avant tout la victoire de la
légalité contre les extrémistes et ce
malgré la tragique disparition de jean
marie tjibaou
oui j'ai trés daniel que la lecture des
résultats d'aujourd'hui pas de doute
jacques lafleur a gagné il sera
majoritaire dans le nouveau congrès mais
l'autre grand vainqueur l'état titre
posthume il s'agit bien sûr de jean
marie tjibaou le faire et tu as fait
aujourd'hui son rang
dans les institutions de calais daniel
des institutions dont il était absent
depuis des années le fn caisse et le
rpcr vont devoir à présent qu gérer leur
pays c'est à dire préparer l'avenir
développer l'économie du territoire pour
être prêts à choisir dans neuf ans entre
indépendance ou non sur de nombreux
points le rpcr et le fn 15 sont donc
souvent voté ensemble dans le nouveau
congrès du territoire leur intérêt
commun est évident en tout cas jusqu'au
référendum de 98 d'ici là beaucoup de
choses peuvent arriver
l'assassinât il ya un mois déjà marie
tjibaou et oeillets owen et wayne est là
pour le rappeler
la calédonie et imprévisible mais ce
pays aime les symboles il verra
peut-être un signe dans le fait que la
première réunion du nouveau congrès aura
lieu le 26 juin le jour anniversaire des
accords de matignon qui avaient ramené
la paix sur le territoire n'oublions pas
la chine qui se normalise ce que l'on
doit traduire par arrestation par
dizaines en série donc épuration
également le tout orchestré par le
gouvernement chinois est répercutée par
la télévision qui nous explique
exactement le contraire de ce que nous
avons vu les semaines passent et jérôme
banni la télévision chinoise diffuse
sans relâche ces images de jeunes gens
arrêtés accusés d'avoir voulu renverser
le gouvernement ou d'avoir attaqué des
véhicules militaires ouvriers ou
étudiants ils sont des centaines dans
les mains de la police
les mauvais traitements ne sont pas
cachés au contraire le pouvoir semble
avoir décidé d'asseoir son autorité
chancelante sur la peur comme beaucoup
d'autres cet homme a été retrouvé grâce
à un document diffusé par une télévision
chinoise aujourd'hui entièrement dévouée
à la propagande et à la délation
des positions virulentes de deux femmes
présentées comme des témoins à charge
la seule voie encore libres du printemps
de pékin
on l'a entendu à hong kong cet après
midi c'est celle de tschaï bi partisane
de la ligne dure électrique le
commandant en chef de la place tiananmen
lors de l'occupation étudiante estonien
de la répression sanglante
naîtra une véritable démocratie
populaire rit-elle de son exil à hong
kong
à bas le fascisme à bas la dictature
militaire
le poste vaincra vive la république
la chine se replie donc sur elle-même
l'union soviétique continue elle son
offensive de charme vis-à-vis de
l'occident est principalement vers le
maillon qu'elle considère comme le plus
réceptif l'allemagne de l'ouest
monsieur gorbatchev arrive demain à bonn
pour une visite officielle de semaine
après la visite du président bush qui
avait proposé de retirer une partie des
troupes américaines en europe si moscou
faisait de même à l'est ce qui n'est pas
le cas jusqu'à présent
même si même si symboliquement quelques
milliers de soldats de l'armée rouge
viennent de quitter l'allemagne de l'est
reportage de notre correspondant à bonn
philippe rochot le départ de ces
militaires soviétiques d'allemagne de
l'est c'est le dernier geste de
gorbatchev
avant sa visite en allemagne fédérale
une vingtaine de vieux blindés et 160
soldats qui prennent le train pour
l'urss moscou mais surtout montré que le
calendrier qui prévoit le départ de cinq
cent mille hommes d'europe de l'est est
respecté mais dans la petite ville de
prenzlau c'est un événement oui on
rentre chez nous en urss avec les
camarades
ça fait huit mois que j'étais ici on est
content de rentrer au pays
moi j'habite dans la région de la volga
quelques 300 personnes étaient là pour
saluer le départ des militaires
soviétiques surtout des ouvriers et des
écoliers qu'on avait amené sur place
mais dont la plupart ne regrette pas le
départ des soviétiques
ils n'étaient pas deux amis et nos
contacts n'étaient pas admis qu avec eux
il n'était pas gentil
par exemple je connais quelqu'un qui a
été traitée de fasciste
alors qu'il n'était même pas née pendant
la guerre on n'y peut rien si hitler a
fait ces choses là
or à chaque fois il nous renvoie à la
figure vous pourrez leur dire qu'ils
sont russes par exemple actuellement ils
sont en plein changement
mais on se fait toujours traité de
fasciste certains soldats étaient là
depuis deux ans mais les troupes
soviétiques étaient souvent relevés et
ont leur évite le contact avec la
population
ils habitaient dans des quartiers
réservés et ne se montra guère depuis le
début de la glace nost 3500 soldats et
officiers soviétiques ont été retirés
d'allemagne de l'est
les 2000 des autres pays socialistes
avec 1800 blindés mais il faudrait que
les soviétiques retire 325 mille hommes
d'europe de l'est pour parvenir à
l'équilibré proposé par george bush
les forces conventionnelles des pays du
pacte de varsovie reste deux à trois
fois supérieurs en nombre à celles de
l'otan
retour en france avec la sécheresse qui
menace d'être peut-être encore plus
sérieuse qu'en 1976 année qui reste bien
entendu dans toutes les mémoires
et pourtant jusqu'à présent cette
sécheresse est invisible il a même plus
ces dernières semaines au mois d'avril
au mois de mai mais le déficit en eau
remonte à l'hiver dernier région
principalement menacer le sud ouest le
sud l'est et l'ouest
c'est dans le sud ouest que nos envoyés
spéciaux sont allés chercher cette
sécheresse josé blanc lapierre et mes
maillots l'on enquêtait dans la montagne
noire la pluie se fait rare depuis
presque un an
la neige des pyrénées évaporé le soleil
n'a pas alimenté ce barrage à moitié
vide
interdiction d'y toucher pour
l'irrigation cette eau est réservé au
robinet la sécheresse un drame pour ceux
qui viennent tout juste d'investir dans
un réseau d'irrigation
on oublie les années passées il mais
sauf en 16es n'étiez pas aussi viable
parce que nous avions pas supporter des
investissements aussi lourd que nous
supportons en 89 pour l'irrigation
l'année se présente d'une manière
catastrophique parce que non seulement
les cultures des terres irriguées ne
marcheront pas puisque nous n'avons pas
d'eau mais même les cultures d'hiver et
les blés en particulier ont été grillés
par une sécheresse relativement précoce
et durable nous avons vu nos blés se
dessécher en quelques jours et on est
évidemment très inquiet autre mesure
d'économie
la fermeture du canal du midi sur 50km
de naurouze à carcassonne réouverture le
1er juillet mais pour un mois seulement
plus grave encore l'eau du robinet
pourrait manquer cet été l'ensemble du
sud ouest est menacée ce qui peut se
passer c'est qu'il fasse beau ce qui est
du soleil qu'il ne pleuve pas assez été
et à ce moment là on
nous risquons d'avoir de très gros
problèmes d'abord pour riri gassion et
ensuite un peu plus tard nous risquons
d'avoir de haut de très sérieux
problèmes d'alimentation en eau potable
de ville puis ceux moins importante mais
à la limite 12 peut être touché
actuellement la vie continue et la
sécheresse ne se voit pas partout les
agriculteurs premiers touchés savent
bien que les pluies d'avril ne suffiront
pas les touristes attendus dans le sud
pourrait avoir à se restreindre
si vous regardiez notre journal de 20h
hier soir vous avez pu suivre une
enquête sur les dramatiques conséquences
d'accidents dus à des bateaux de
plaisance conscient de ce problème dans
la mesure où les embarcations de toutes
sortes se multiplient l'été sur les
côtes
trois cent mille dont le seul littoral
méditerranéen et bien les pouvoirs
publics ont décidé de se doter des
moyens d'intervenir mais le droit
maritime est encore relativement
impuissants à sanctionner sévèrement les
infractions ou les imprudences en quête
de thierry calmette et michel jeannot
beauce
oui moi je messieurs
voyez ce poster votre avis vous
accueille pour la sécurité pouvait
sécurité douanes
oui les six douaniers du lycée rios code
delta foxtrot peuvent aussi contrôler
les infractions la navigation et la
sécurité gis les fusées ce plaisancier
n'a rien à se reprocher mais ça ne le
protège pas contre tous les risques
j'en passe la vérité ça vous est déjà
arrivé
recevez pas rêver xv pas cher payé trop
coupé en deux par le bateau la zone de
tous les dangers les 300 mètres à partir
du rivage sur le littoral méditerranéen
6 millions d'estivants hibbard battront
cet été
la vitesse est impérativement limitée à
5 noeuds soit 10 km heure environ dans
la chasse aux chauffards de la mer delta
foxtrot rapporte directement au crous
mer la mission première de ce centre de
coordination reste le sauvetage de
l'assistance mais les 60 hommes qui
veillent d'ici 24 heures sur 24 sur un
territoire allant de perpignan à menton
et s'étendant jusqu'à la sardaigne
relaie aussi des opérations de
répression dispose des moyens conjugués
de toutes les armes et administrations
concernées selon les cas ils vous
aideront vous constaterez en infraction
qui sont par exemple de ne pas tenir
compte du tout des conditions météo et
de ne s'en préoccupe et qu'une fois en
mer c'est à dire trop tard ou tout
simplement de ne pas importer le
matériel de signalisation de détresse
les fusées rouges ou une radio qui
marche ou encore ceux qui plus
graves est plus bête je dirai simplement
de ne pas vérifier le bon fonctionnement
du moteur ou tout simplement si les
plats sont faits avant de partir au
maire
une heure de vol de cet hélicoptère 35me
francs les irresponsables nous coûte
cher
l'an dernier le cross med a enregistré
deux mille opérations cette année déjà
plus de 5 130 interventions à leur actif
le plus délicat matérialiser l'excès de
vitesse
l'électronique et le radar au service de
la loi quand votre tour infractions qui
dépasse à moins de 300 mètres des côtes
la vitesse de 5 noeuds on agit donc tu
as le mans grâce à son corps ada et
ensuite on agit avec une opération coup
de poing avec un ou plusieurs navires
administratif qui nous permette sur des
bases de feta d'évaluer la vitesse et
donc de construction et ses différents
services manque de vedettes légère plus
adapté à la situation ou d'hélicoptères
toujours très onéreux la réglementation
commence à peine à prendre en compte des
nouveaux engins comme les boudins tracts
et où les scooters de la mère michel qui
n'a pas quitté 180 la navigation de
plaisance étant rattachée au droit
maritime international
la limitation de responsabilité civile
atténue les conséquences des excès voir
que les gens sont surtout sensibles à la
responsabilité pénale
s'ils savent que effectivement lorsque
on les contrôle rang et notamment dans
les infractions graves comme la vitesse
excessive dans une zone on peut trouver
des baigneurs aider d'autres usagers de
la mer et que les amendes de tourner
autour de 8 à 10 villes feront et que ce
sont quand même les amendes conséquentes
et je voudrais préciser que le contrôle
est une des facettes le plus gros volet
qui doit intervenir dans nos dans nos
fonctions est un volet d'information
mais pour l'instant pas de possibilité
de retrait de permis de naviguer padel
côte est en mer non plus alors attention
un bateau comme une voiture peut
représenter une arme mortelle la
politique
auchan ce dimanche est pas austère les
passionnés de publicité comprendront
d'abord les rénovateurs de l'opposition
renforcée par quelques autres
personnalités ont choisi de méditer au
monastère de la chartreuse dans l'isère
sujet de réflexion quelle opposition et
pourquoi faire reportage de gilles
leclerc et vincent meyer ceux qui
cherchent et qui trouvent ce qu'ils
cherchent
en attendant de trouver la solution il
est bien difficile en tout cas pour les
cadettes de l'opposition de grimper
ensemble du même pas certes alain
carignon a réussi son pari réunir malgré
l'absence depuis je viens quasiment
toutes les sensibilités de la droite et
du centre rénovateurs ou pas issus de la
même génération mais tous loin de là ne
sont pas d'accord sur la méthode rénové
l'opposition louis comment ces lacs
éclater les différences entre les
centristes qui attendent les rénovateurs
qui regrette de ne pas avoir osé pour
les européennes les léotard dhien qui
reste discret et la jeune garde
chiraquienne parfois agacé il y a des
divergences mais on se parle on
réfléchit les aînés ne sont pas là et on
se prend même parfois à rêver de
l'avenir dans une atmosphère sereine et
cordiale mais une fois descendu des
sommets malgré l'eau de source et le
bonheur la réalité reprend vite le
dessus
certains et j'en suis pense que nous
devons aller vers une opposition
beaucoup plus uni une opposition mieux
organisés dans une formation pluraliste
mais
mais qui existe qui soit cohérente et
d'autres pensent qu'il vaut peut-être
mieux avoir deux formations voire trois
il faut avoir l'honnêteté et le courage
de dire que tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord sur tout il ya des routines ya
des appareils et tout ça ce sont des
pesanteurs qui font que parce qu'on est
différent on veut pas se parler
au fond nous avons tous le même objectif
qui est celui d'aboutir à une
construction positive de l'union de
l'opposition
voilà au moins une vision optimiste de
cette journée des retrouvailles mais
qu'elle sera demain le véritable visage
de l'opposition
la réponse reste encore dans le
brouillard même si pour tous il reste
impératif de trouver rapidement la bonne
route sous peine de nouvel échec mais en
tout cas ils ont pris l'air plus
populaires le chef de file de la liste
communiste aux européennes philippe
herzog avait aujourd'hui dimanche
entraîner ses troupes dans un pique
nique à bagneux dans la banlieue
parisienne bruno roger petit didier
d'armes philippe herzog adopte le style
force tranquille au grand meeting la
tête de liste du parti communiste semble
préférer désormais les réunions en
comité restreint
le candidat du parti s'y soumet aux
interrogations d'un public souvent ati à
sa cause il y est question de paix de
désarmement d'écologie d'antoine
waechter
l'occasion pour philippe érables de
condamner le leader écologiste qui
refusent de collaborer avec lui sur ces
thèmes
j'aime autant vous dire que les
pacifistes scandinave allemands ou
anglais
ils en ont rien à fiche si vous n'êtes
vous pas ils sont avant tout des
pacifistes donc qui se retrouve
évidemment avec des confitures des
combats mais vestaires qui se conduit
comme un pur politiciens à la française
lui adore faire quelque chose alors donc
il est prêt à le refaire
philippe herzog espère concurrencer
antoine waechter sur le terrain du
désarmement et de l'écologie le 18 juin
pourtant le communiste et l'écologiste
entreront une et deux au parlement
européen mais ils ne siégeront pas côte
à côte
en attendant la campagne continue et
philippe herzog comme tous les candidats
poursuit sa formation de futurs députés
européens
voilà et philippe hersoy sera demain
matin l'invité des quatre vérités à 6h45
une halte dans ce journal avec un
document la télévision iranienne qui
estime que la presse occidentale a mal
rendu compte de l'émotion et du chagrin
du peuple iranien à la suite de la mort
dimanche dernier de l'ayatollah comédie
vient à l'instant il ya quelques minutes
à peine de nous faire parvenir ce
document que vous allez pouvoir regarder
il s'agit des cérémonies du 7e jour de
deuil qui ont réuni un million de
personnes ce dimanche à tes filles et
garçons comme celle usage dans l'islam
le septième jour de la mort de
l'ayatollah khomeiny a été célébré
aujourd'hui la foule se comptent par
centaines de milliers de fidèles on
parle de plus d'un million de personnes
face à cette marée humaine le
quadrillage installé par l'armée la
police iranienne est complètement
débordé la circulation dans téhéran a
une fois encore été paralysé plusieurs
heures avant le début de la cérémonie
il n'était plus possible d'approcher du
cimetière à moins de 13 km sur la tombe
de l'ayatollah des containers de bateaux
ont été empilés pour former un mausolée
un avion a largué de l'eau de rose sur
les pèlerins et les hélicoptères lancer
eux des milliers de fleurs 250
ambulances sont prêtes à intervenir
ainsi qu'un millier de médecins et
infirmiers on déplore déjà deux morts et
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
déjà évanoui
passons aux stores maintenant avant le
tennis de très belles compétitions
d'abord les 24 heures du mans
automobiles remporté par mercedes dont
c'était le grand retour francis
maroteaux le mans samedi 16 heures 55
voitures au départ pour une triangulaire
mercedes jaguar porsche après un
chassé-croisé durant les premières
heures de course et la nuit mercedes
épargné par les incidents mène la ronde
mais les incidents
regardez un bout de gomme par terre la
raison et bien tout simplement pescarolo
éclatent à l'arrière-gauche à 300 km
heure dans les hunaudières
l'américain dobson voiture en flammes
mais heureusement il sort indemne eynden
aussi le japonais takahashi et puis le
grand frisson du français pessiot au
volant de sa peugeot wm grosse frayeur
mais plus de crainte
en revanche pour les mercedes vainqueur
avec eux qu'une masse premier et avec
bâle 2e enfin troisième la porsche de
bob wollek
succès français dans le tour d'italie
cycliste laurent fignon vainqueur et qui
revient donc au premier plan après un
passage à vide de plusieurs saisons
olivier rey laurent fignon voit la vie
en rose
cinq ans après avoir perdu le tour
d'italie par la faute des organisateurs
sign on appris aujourd'hui sa revanche
il a également et surtout démontré qu'il
possède à nouveau les moyens physiques
de remporter un grand tour national
après plusieurs années gâchées par une
succession de blessures
cet après midi dans la dernière étape un
contre la montre de 53 km enlevée par le
polonais piasecki laurent fignon a
réussi à ne concéder que 15 secondes à
son principal rival l'italien flavio
ghiloni troisième de l'état en terminant
5e du contre-la-montre
le français remporte donc son premier
tir au ras des minutes 15 secondes
d'avancé sur guy pony l'objectif
désormais de signes ont gagné un
troisième tour de france est encore plus
confiance pour le tout je pense que je
marche encore mieux parce que les
difficultés tant plus grande encore
m'améliorer ça va être encore
paul est un super coup voilà et puis
l'événement du jour maintenant donc que
vous avez pu suivre pendant quatre
heures cet après midi en direct sur
antenne 2 la finale du tournoi de tennis
de roland garros vainqueur celui qui
avait d'abord étonné avant de confirmer
donc l'américain michael chang plus
jeune vainqueur du tournoi depuis sa
création
17 ans et trois mois tout juste gens ma
mère on s'installe on regarde à 17 ans
et rembrandt à la coupe de l'un des plus
grands tournois du monde que l'on a
surpris tous les pronostiqueurs et que
l'on entre dans l'histoire
il faut bien trouver une explication c
je remercie jésuites réussi parce que
sans lui alors vraiment je ne suis rien
pourtant ce n'est pas jésus-christ qui a
joué cinq sets cet après-midi face aux
troisièmes meilleurs joueurs du monde
stefan edberg
c'est peut-être lui qui l'a inspiré
surtout qu'il a aidé à déstabiliser son
adversaire lui faire oublier qu'il était
un joueur volleyeurs et l'obliger à
jouer au fond du court à pouss balle ce
qu'il a usé psychologiquement avant de
le faire physiquement
ed baird
cet après midi n'a visiblement pas
compris le rôle qu'il avait dans ce film
il a joué tout faux
et pourtant stefan edberg le plus beau
toucher une raquette du circuit la plus
belle volée aussi a eu des éclairs de
génie
3 une partie se gagne en jouant tous les
points chang les a tous joué
parfois pour rien d'autres fois en
revance tout en usant son adversaire
dans un interminable échange il a petit
à petit prouver non seulement qu'ils
pouvaient tenir cinq sets mais surtout
qu'il ne se rendrait jamais
rien de tel pour vous d'évoluer
stefan edberg va cauchemarder sans doute
encore longtemps à ne pas oublier il ya
tout de même eu un vainqueur français au
tournoi de roland garros celui des
juniors en finale fabrice santoro le
français donc a battu l'américain palmer
en trois sets prenons l'air un tout
petit peu maintenant pour terminer ce
journal la saison des festivals d'été
commencent le départ est donné à
montpellier pour un mois avec le
printemps des comédiens il y a il y aura
des vedettes francis huster laurent
terzieff michel galabru et ce qui fait
l'originalité de ce festival c'est qu'il
rayonne dans tout le département de
l'hérault associant professionnels et
amateurs reportage de george v go est
ivre je crois qu'il fallait prendre de
la hauteur pour mieux comprendre un
festival dans l'une des originalités et
être éclatés sur 14 communes du
département de l'hérault de la plus
petite à la plus grande montpellier qui
offre au château d'eau trois lieux de
spectacles différents
pour sa troisième édition le printemps
des comédiens totalisera en un mois
50000 spectateurs autour de 34 pièces
dont plusieurs cette année comme marat
sade se rattache au bicentenaire de la
révolution
à claret 500 habitants il a fallu
emprunter des chaises au village voisin
même galabru se préoccupent de leur
installation en compagnie du maire à
quelques kilomètres de là pézenas qui
connu les débuts de molière on s'y
félicitent d'une renaissance du théâtre
ce n'est pas sans raison que le premier
printemps des comédiens s'est déroulé
sous le signe de molière de grands
comédiens sont venus à pézenas
li a eu un temps mort pour le théâtre je
crois que la venue du printemps des
comédiens sera la marque et le nouvel
essor du théâtre pézenas à 3 tours
d'hélice le petit port de mèze le
théâtre ni été connue que par la
télévision
le curé de la paroisse a prêté le parvis
de son église afin que tous les enfants
de la commune puissent voir les
comédiens et leur parler de parler à des
comédiens comme à la télé
et vos parents sont contents vous
fassiez un peu de théâtre avec les
comédiens moi c'est ma mère qui m'a
poussé à faire du théâtre mais qu'elle a
entendu salle m'a dit vas-y
d'abord ça nous apprend les expressions
c'est le plaisir de jouer à wow ainsi
apporter le plaisir de la comédie
vivante à ceux qui ne l'ont jamais goûté
former un public c'est au delà de bien
d'autres méritent la plus noble vocation
de ce festival
oui et demain dans télématin partir de
6h30 en direct de montpellier bien vous
saurez tout sur ce festival
le tiercé maintenant voilà
voici les chevaux qu'il fallait jouer
cet après-midi dans le prix de diane à
chantilly le prix des élégants du temps
qui rapporte et 3574 offrant 50 centimes
si vous avez joué l'aspect 14 et le 12
et pour ce qui concerne le quarté bien
ajouter le qu'après vous gagnez un peu
plus de 31 mille francs voilà ce journal
est terminée tout de suite après les
prévisions météo avec josé dans la
pierre aux alentours de minuit vous
retrouvez philippe gassot pour les
toutes dernières informations et puis
demain soir à 20 heures ici même
christine ockrent quant à moi je vous
retrouverai d'abord mardi pour un star à
la barre spéciale consacrée aux
problèmes de l'immigration et puis bien
sûr samedi prochain je vous souhaite une
excellente semaine
bonsoir